in all its 75 years Israel has never
seen a day like this
hour by hour through the morning the
protests on the streets grew and the
country quickly started to shut down
flights taking off from the
International Airport were stopped
because staff walked out
major shopping malls closed their doors
and McDonald's shut their restaurants
Nationwide
[Music]
the country's largest trade unions went
on strike and Israel's embassies around
the world shut as diplomatic staff
stayed at home
in Tel Aviv were some of the largest
protests have taken place the city's
mayor announced that there would be no
more municipality Services until further
notice
Israel's political center around the
knesset parliament in Jerusalem was
gridlocked inside and out it's really
scary it's scary to think of this
country possibly going down the road to
dictatorship or theocracy or or some
other implausible idea of what might
happen what do you fear is happening
a war a war for democracy yes
might be a turning point the things that
happened in the past few days uh are
they've never happened before look how
many good people that support democracy
support liberalism and
yeah I I think the justice will win
Benjamin Netanyahu who was out of sight
locked in talks with his Coalition
ministers boxed into a corner of his own
making
it's now almost five o'clock in the
afternoon almost six and a half hours
after billion Netanyahu was rumored to
be giving a statement and calling a halt
to the legislation and yet a part of a
short tweet urging for the protest to be
peaceful to which they are we've heard
nothing the longer the Prime Minister
remains silent the more they feel that
they have him on the ropes
eventually almost exactly 24 hours after
he sacked his defense minister and
sparked this crisis Netanyahu went on
national television and took aim at
those who oppose him
there is one minority that is willing to
tear this country to Pieces it behaves
with violence ignites fires threatens to
hurt politicians and inflamed Civil War
[Music]
when there's an opportunity to avoid
Civil War through dialogue I as prime
minister am taking time out for dialogue
this is the first time the government
has given an inch to the pressure of the
protests the decision to pause the
reforms opens a window for the
opposition to negotiate a compromise but
the reforms haven't been halted and so
the protests won't stop the fight for
the future of Israel is not over
Aleister bunker Sky News in Jerusalem